bats have impressive echolocation skills  most of the time unfortunately they have  a bit of a problem with smooth surfaces  bats navigate in the dark by listening  for the echoes of their own  high-frequency calls objects with rough  surfaces reflect sound waves in many  different directions but smooth surfaces  can act as an acoustic mirror reflecting  most of the sound away from the incoming  bat only when the bat is directly over  this metal sheet  can it detect a few reflected sound  waves the bats in this experiment often  only realized the metal plate was there  at the very last minute  none of these bats were injured but in  the wild smooth glass on the outside of  buildings can be an invisible Menace for  echolocating bats  you  [Music]